I also put therapy is feminist a
feminist want to get into your family so
they'll say oh in order to save the
marriage you need to go to therapy when
in the past we used to go to our
grandparents our parents for advice but
now their whole idea is let's Outsource
the family let's make the state the
family that is feminine cool you know
the moms used to be really involved in
teaching their kids now you send the
kids to the state which we all know all
of these institutions all of these um
all of these institutions are run by
feminists it's back my last one the
school the sports work it's all feminist
now again never said anyone's a bad
person whatever this is just observing
the society okay ladies please stay with
me the